[Music]
conan o'brien here for another edition
of behind the nonsense where we talk
about the nonsense we're going to talk
now about a piece that was very popular
that we did uh for a while i think
almost every time we went to comic-con i
believe i think every year i think every
year we went to comic-con we would do
auditions for whatever the new big movie
was and uh the word was out that there
would be a new han solo again
a young han solo and the word was out uh
for who might get this role and we
claimed that we got a hold of the
audition tapes uh for
who was going up for the roles and you
can actually see famous celebrities
audition and so let's show this and then
we'll talk about it
name please bill hater
okay so he's young right okay i want to
do the kept running 16 parsecs mom
[Applause]
he's on his way to do errands or
whatever
i'm also batman
just wanted to go deeper no we're good
thank you down there
okay
[Applause]
name please melissa mccarthy
you haven't heard of the millennium
falcon
it's the ship that made the kessel run
in less than 12 parsnips it's parsecs
parceps is funnier
nobody knows what a parsec is
parsnips they're going to be like what
have you seen star wars i've seen a good
portion of one of them he's a small
wizard boy in the school
in the hills
young taunton
packer backer this is a skateboard
oh you know what i could do his young
jabba the hutt young job of the hud's
like
[Applause]
[Music]
you've never heard the millennium falcon
it's the ship that made the kessel run
in less than 12 parsecs now get off of
my plane
that's from a different harrison ford
that doesn't matter
dade i'm sorry
[Applause]
king
great kid
it don't get cocky
[Applause]
this is like a big spoiler like when han
solo was young was he pakistani because
like
i'm pakistani i will say if you don't
cast me in this you're racist
never tell me the odds
how's that i'm really good at like just
never hearing the odds like the odds no
never tell me the odds dude
[Applause]
never tell me that no
never tell me to ask no
this way oh no
you want me to do tell me what you want
you never tell me to ask no
name please
uh
so
before we film anything can have a quick
can i just ask
this is for young han solo
uh well let's let's uh let's let's give
it a shot as the
as the kids say
you never heard of the millennium falcon
it's the ship that made the kessel run
in less than 12 parsecs
if i get the part i'll research believe
you me what all that means so i can give
it a little more credibility i'll know
what i'm talking about here i'm just
kind of reading it i can't say i'm all
that familiar with the entire universe
or phraseology the crazy thing is
it's true
the force the jedi
all of it
it's all true
hey i like that i think i get you see
what that gave
[Applause]
okay young chewbacca is uh
hey guys hey when i hit puberty you
better watch out
no no
never tell me the odds okay han solo
doesn't use a lightsaber my version of
him does
he uses a lightsaber all the time saber
what lightsaber you get out
great kid don't be cocky no
you suck you suck this whole [ __ ] show
sucks how about this
wow that
well i mean it's such a great concept i
mean it's so simple basically we ask all
our friends to help us out and then
they're all auditioning for this part
and then it's just so much fun
they're very badass they're very bad at
it right yeah very successful but i love
watching them all it's so much fun to
watch them all play with it you know
also one of the rare chances for the
writers to work with a celebrity like
you know we sometimes do but we're told
not to approach it yes
it's really funny we really are just
trapped in a room with two writers and
there's there's no where there's nowhere
to go you got jodie foster yes one of
the most iconic and and she has she's at
the you know at the behest yes of uh two
nerds she's in
a conference room with you know paper on
the wall but just to hear a producer
come up and like on some of the other
ones you know like jesse levi dan uh don
cheadle's ready
and also they're they are almost i mean
you can see right there they're just
having fun in their game and they're
screwing around and it's basically we're
giving them a jungle gym
and
they're they're playing on it everyone's
playing on it in a different way but so
exciting at comic-con standing on that
stage in the dark with all those crazy
fans there watching all of these massive
celebrities pretend to be han solo and
it was a long slog like we would start
doing this months before i was going to
say look at the group levi i think
pitched that three or four months in
advance after they announced the
young han solo movie so he just thought
ahead basically because we had to
put two or three together a month well
someone was so ready for like jodie
foster pitching we're so apologetic
like first of all you shouldn't we
shouldn't be asking you to do this but
would you mind with and we have a
costume and then of course she was so
game for everything but so deadpan we
pitched it all and we're like oh did we
[ __ ] up and she's like yeah no it's all
great i'll to i'll try all that and then
she was up for it all put on a costume
it's so much fun and bill hader and
melissa mccarthy just like mike i mean
we're basically sitting there
improvising with them kind of maybe not
so
they were just so funny just so
hilariously generous awesome we did a
bunch of them i mean i don't know yeah
we did a bunch of auditions uh wolverine
was the first one yeah we realized at a
certain point it doesn't have to be a
real story yeah yeah you know like we
don't have to wait for them to we can
just say they're looking for a new a new
hermione yeah yeah yeah we're all based
on real movies that were coming and then
another thing that came up was like 50
cent felt like a long shot and they were
like we don't even know if he does
comedy and then he was so playful that
bit where his security's with him
for the audition is that he had his real
bodyguard with him but they he didn't
want that guy to be on camera because
that's a real security threat that's how
the idea came up it was just on the day
we're like could we put your bodyguard
and he was like no no no and we thought
he didn't like the idea he's like no i
just can't show my guy if you can put
someone in there though i love the idea
funny if he left with the actor
bodyguard
who was no good at being a bodyguard
he's trained in stage
50 sense attack and this guy's using
bamboo
stage combat bamboo
uh his bodyguard's been our sound guy
for 18. that's right
very good
they're both happy never dropped a note
[Music]
well that was fun that was fun to look
at i really that's nice that's all i got
man